we're all here jake's here live we need
an interesting hello we're here live
on the corridor
on the corridor cast we're here live
all right jake is on the dulcimer
hi jake watson on dulcimer what do we
got on lead guitar
it's sam what's up i'm sam
hi sam famous from such videos as
oh red versus blue versus blue
yeah
and who's on uh you got nico on the
handpan you might be know
know me from such videos as um son of a
dungeon episode eight yes actually
specifically episode five i'm in that
one okay yeah are you the guy that's in
the one the guy that's yeah i'm i am the
the d and d table in that oh okay yeah i
remember that yeah yeah
yeah the table yeah okay so clutch
all right ready
should we lay out a chord progression or
just go for it no it's just keep it all
in d on d all right let's go
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
we gotta practice more yeah
that's my second time picking up that
instrument so um
maybe the third time it'll be on the
next episode well it's twice as easy as
guitar since there's it is twice as easy
as guitar yeah that way it's really like
i've picked it up four times
under that logic
yeah
um so uh
you may have heard episode eight the
finale of son of a dungeon is live on
corridor digital.com and episode two
it's a little secret for all your
troutons it's coming out on sunday on
youtube yeah on court or crew youtube i
know perhaps we can entice you with our
wares
perhaps you may be interested in our
ways we've got one not we've got two not
one but two episodes available so i have
the perfect thing we've we've created a
series of adventurers yes
it's cool it's pretty intense
the last step is great sam's a little in
shock because he just got done exporting
it yeah it's
so much
so much work way too much work for a d d
show but
like i say that i i simultaneously
love every second of it but yeah um yeah
wow no yeah it was great watching the
finale you guys did an incredible job
yeah it's pretty intense it's pretty
intense
it's like full on avengers yeah yeah
the dishwasher the dishwasher should we
call the episode that the dishwasher
okay
yeah it comes out tomorrow as of this
recording right yeah
yeah it'll be out by the time this
this is out yep yeah
um so then yeah and then look for uh
episode two on uh youtube if uh you if
you if you can't chill out
an email for a two week free trial
sam
what are your big now you're done right
what are your big life-changing lessons
that you've learned from such an
endeavor as son of a dungeon
life chain oh god life i don't know if
i've learned well i mean i've learned
stuff on how to make that specific show
faster to make
yeah i mean jeez gosh we gotta do that
next time that's that's really those are
the big takeaways
yeah
we need another effects artist well yeah
i can't i can't be the vfx lead on it
because
you know there's too many other things
i'm also mastering the audio carmichael
like does sound design and then i take
it all and make it balanced
and then
you know i don't know that i'm tweaking
all the comps and stuff for the green
screen shots
all the unreal stuff oh my god it's way
too many shots i had i should do the i
should do the true tally of how many
shots you should yeah we should do a
little post on that that would be cool
it's pretty cool to see like a
screenshot of the uh
uh you know and you look at the edit in
premiere for the last episode and it's
just like
real footage real footage cg real
footage real and just like oh my god
like how did that happen there was a few
moments in episode 8 where we're
entirely in the cg world for like
long periods of time as you're going
through this cavern yeah yeah and but it
helps so much because like
yeah each time i well the the way i
decide if we're dropping those shots in
this
i just play the edit and it's like
should i be seeing this like is this
something i need to see like to get
right
like half of that last episode is yes
yeah yeah and the way that you revealed
the uh
the the moving walls
yeah was really cool how we didn't know
as players yeah yeah yeah the audience
sees it it doesn't spoil anything no
it's cool yeah it's pretty sweet yeah
hopefully uh yeah
hopefully we can take all the stuff and
then actually like apply it to either
like another season or
making cooler crew videos because
there's like a ton of
a ton of stuff i mean you saw like the
bowling alley animations i'm doing that
on unreal now it's like okay yeah
there's there's
there's some other benefits and
carmichael if you're listening to this
um you're gonna have to learn some
unreal too yeah only like a rudimentary
level of unreal yeah like the director's
about as much as i know about afterwards
like a director you know a director who
comes in and is like
knows the names of some buttons yeah and
then understands that there's a camera
somewhere and you render it eventually
like that level yeah well it's funny
because
i don't know very much about the actual
like intricacies of the tools of
vfx and cgi but
i understand like the concepts and how
they apply to when you're actually
filming and when you're actually editing
and actually doing the work
so that it's true you can actually
achieve like a level of
understanding uh
with yeah
are we are we good to talk spoilers on
this episode i feel like i mean like the
finale just dropping like should we talk
about spoilers right now let's do it
let's do it all right let's enter a
spoiler okay this is officially your
spoiler zone if you haven't seen it take
a time out
go and watch it watch all the other
episodes yeah why are you talking about
this instead and come back listen to
this afterwards sam's like been working
on this for months and he's sitting here
in this podcast i want to talk about it
it's so stupid we've been working on it
since before february like the first
crew cuts episode that came out about
figuring this out was like last year
a year ago yeah
so i guess spoilers it's been i mean i
have done other things i have
if you look at the videos on the crew
channel
i have done other things but it feels
like i haven't done a single other thing
he slept and woke up and that's it
all right so here's my question
what if we died in episode eight oh my
on i was i was hoping it would happen
i was like but yeah but but the big
thing i really could have happened
oh yeah absolutely but the i i was
kind of incorrectly playing the mind
player characters we kind of played it
and we did all this stuff
and i read again and
i'm going to i'll fix this you know if
we're going to play more
but the mind player characters basically
have like certain big creatures in d the
way they by the way you actually make
these creatures super powerful
is you basically give them free actions
there's like a small each ultra powerful
character in d d basically gets like a
small list of like two or three like
legendary actions which mean
they can do them
whenever they want
even if it's not their turn okay and
like in as we've as you saw in like
normal turn-based stuff like okay yeah
you can you got to strategize take them
out especially like the last mega big
one
it you guys take them out and it's and
like we even afterwards like it was so
hectic and like so much we were figuring
so much out on the fly but
i went through from everything from the
water pit to the very end and
just double check stuff to make sure it
doesn't come off as us just like go like
whatever yeah
it kind of comes off like that but i
went through the whole thing and you can
it it's it all falls into the like the
rules of the game really well actually
and keeps things outside of dee's
dual crossbow attack that i don't know
that's a house rule it might be but but
like yeah so
you
you could have died if i was using the
legendary action thing against everyone
because
it's like the whole like blast thing
blah blah all that stuff happening it
would be happening like like
way more often it would be like
twice per round and people would just be
getting like pummeled and those aren't
rough yeah so like but that's usually
how that character gets played which is
like all right i'm psychic i'm not gonna
slap you it's like i just all i'm trying
to do is stun you long enough to eat
your brain
and
when it's like four people versus one
it's like four people
go have huge powerful attacks and then
it's like oh [ __ ] i only i can try this
once but even yeah like you know there's
so many other factors so anyways yeah i
thought for sure
was gonna die what would happen if
someone died would you die that's it
and then
it becomes part of the cool story
so you've been cool if like just the
heroes died in episode 8 and like that's
it ladies and gentlemen and the chances
of everyone dying i felt we're going to
be pretty low i would propose a
challenge i always hope for at least one
but yeah i feel like in next season
somebody needs to go
like one of us needs to die well i'm not
gonna make it happen i'll help set the
scene for someone's death but
i hope no none of us die next season
yeah i mean i don't i do too i i hope i
hope we i hope we live but without the
real threat of character death
like
you know
it's just
what can you do and i get it because
like you have four level eight
characters plus a cleric
going against
one one level nine or no level ten
characters right
critical or uh
challenge rating 10 or level 10.
challenge rating 10 means the character
is well they change you know i don't i
don't really remember but
you know right
i counted the health points that were
knocked off of it and it went to zero
i'm like all right i feel like
i feel like you need to do
like take the main character
the main boss
and then if we're level 10 or whatever
so that's 40 total make them level 20
between 27. oh no we get our
here's what we do level 10
and you make
one boss level 16.
um well
uh yeah i mean the levels honestly
are i like as i was saying like this
concept of legendary actions like but
think about this it's a big boss fight
it's a huge mega powerful creature
there's four little guys trying to take
them out they got powerful spells but
this guy's super powerful so the concept
of like the legendary actions is okay
i get to interrupt the chains and like
the strategy right and right it keeps
things a little bit more difficult and
and so it's like oh what if we do this
water lightning horns whatever and in
the middle of that i'm like oh
and so like
it it it prevents
the
i guess the it lowers the uh the ceiling
of how like how
how much yeah how much
teamwork starts paying off right right
um and not to say it's like it's yeah
once again it's not trying like to win d
but right i think from a perspective of
like oh keeping people on edge a little
bit more as far as
having their characters die yeah it
definitely helps that
yeah i feel like
had we not pulled off like this big
group kill
effort i feel like we would have lost
well without the water spell
i don't know what would i don't again i
was saying this at the end of the
episode but i don't know how how would
we even have gotten over to the creature
in the first yeah we're gonna go in the
water because it's all filled with
literally without control water
yeah it's like you would have just been
stuck there twimothy have like floated
us over there
i don't know no
maybe i like i i was i kept that
character kind of light that that
character by the way that was like not
supposed to be such a super important
character
and it was just like he's like the one
orphan who's he it's just
going back to that third episode it's
just like okay i was like all right uh
i'm gonna make uh like four characters
that are infected and make them all like
kind of different yeah so that way they
all have different there's always
different approaches on how to like deal
with each one
and then it just so happens that
like the kid character
was uh immune to coronavirus
right he didn't get it yet
so
how did when did you decide that like
twimothy was not
so he's obviously still infected but
he's not
so what is that how when did you decide
that was that early on when you were
like
what this isn't going to affect
everybody the same or
uh well i was thinking a little bit as
far as like
uh uh um
man or did you kind of make it up as you
went along no i i can't i don't say it i
don't remember too much with the
big picture stuff yeah but the main
thing was that like very quickly in the
episode you're like oh here's a sick kid
have the cleric basically
fix the kids keep him alive long enough
yeah and so with the way the story was
moving it was like this is kind of like
a natural fit to right keep keep the
character around and like
give it like a
like a next level so it's not just like
a oh it's a rescue mission yeah it's
like have it become something more than
that hey do you see this tiny guitar
right here and how it comes in one
beautiful little package well guess what
you can get all of your stock asset
needs to come in one beautiful little
package too courtesy of today's sponsors
storyblocks they're the one-stop shop
for all your stock asset needs for
creators and businesses alike we use
them all the time over here at corridor
digital and let me tell you why not only
do they make beautiful sounds through
their audio assets but also you can get
high quality 4k b-roll you can get
images motion graphics after effects
templates and more and you can get all
of that with an unlimited all-access
plan that gives you the ability to
download anything you want from the site
as much as you want and use it in any
kinds of projects worldwide it's a
global thing guys and just like the
sounds that you can make with this
guitar you can take the assets and bring
them out globally to the world bring
them out into the world they're
constantly updating their library and
that's another reason that we love them
we can go on there and we're never going
to find the same thing twice if you're
already a serious professional creator
and you're part of a team well talk to
your team leader about an enterprise
plan whenever you're trying to find that
little thing that's going to make and
take your video to the next level and
you don't want to go out and create an
after effects template from scratch or
you don't want to go out and try to get
b-roll on your own storybox is going to
save you a ton of time and a ton of
money if you're serious about making
videos if you're serious about creating
you're gonna need a stock asset solution
for your creativity a huge thanks to
them for always sponsoring the podcast
and if you guys are interested head on
over to
or cast storyblocks.comcast click the
link in the description below and the
next time you see a tiny little guitar i
want you to think of story blocks don't
think of me think of story blocks okay
all right well good great i'm glad you
know this now and uh let's get back to
the podcast
so what is this dark world this this
dark
what is this dark what is this dark
world
it's called my mind
no no where the spiderman came from
not to mention spider-man
we're just going to get into like sam
and carmichael's nerdy dnd backstory
stuff look i want to hear about this so
all right so the idea is uh
at the very first we never show this
once during the entire season but i made
this map
okay
like this big drawing this this of the
the landscape yeah to show the
relationship of everything
and there's one very specific thing that
wasn't ever visited in it there was
there was cecilton there was the
orphanage and all that stuff and the
banner there was wentinghamshire all
that stuff and then on literally there
written down
there's this huge mining area that's
right next to wentinghamshire
that we never like really brought up or
kept talking about you try to get us to
go on a side quest there
uh maybe
the big side quest was
find the lost merchandise that's what
yes
[Laughter]
nico shut it down like really hard
he's like i'm not doing a [ __ ] side
quest
and i was like i took that as a positive
sign that things were going well
tell me my lost bag of merchandise
what was at the end of the lost
merchandise
um
that's a way to get to the like the
horde that comes and starts over that's
like a faster route to get to that kind
of story line okay because you guys end
up going out and you're like what the
[ __ ] are all these people like walking
towards the city doing and so
it he it was going to tee off that a
little sooner
but
you know then cecilton would have been
destroyed
potentially well it already kind of was
yeah
but i was like yeah i mean from the
get-go it's like all right during the
course of that play session it's like
everyone in the town who's infected is
going to turn into a mind flare unless
someone steps in
oh okay like that was the goal so
timothy not turning into a mind player
was because of everyone
taking the cleric character and making
sure he's sticking with him right
keeping him uh
yeah so
okay
all right so because that's what i'm
curious about because we gotta
we gotta do something with little
timothy yeah next season so that that's
the idea is that all right so you go
down there's what's under there there's
some mines there's [ __ ] going on that's
some name for it it's a backstory the
decal that's
okay and it's true because like the
writer character is like specifically a
character in that pantheon of in that
universe of dnd okay
so
let's go there i want to go there i mean
it's happened if you watched the last
shot of the episode you're we're going
there yeah i saw it so i think a
question that like a bunch of people
have and i have as well very frequently
you know looking at this whole game
like how much did you actually plan and
how much of it was you just going like
i'm gonna make this up on the spot
because this is what happened tons of it
is planned it's like you it's like it's
a 3d story that you know that's the big
thing where it's like
you don't write linearly what you want
to have happen you basically like i
ended up having like a like i have a
google doc where i've actually i
i was writing out ideas and i was like
there's got to be a way to format this
so i can like have reference basically
as we're playing as far as
what's happening and if if someone goes
here how do i prevent myself from coming
up with something on the fly which can
kind of create plot holes pretty quickly
yeah and
because it's all like i'll forget [ __ ] i
say right and thankfully
if if it's important and someone cares
about it they'll be like hey
yeah
that's not how it happened
um
what let's see
i i can pull one up though because it's
it really is helpful um
where is it so there's still um there's
still a tadpole in uh nico's head
okay so yes yeah yeah it ends with d
being uh restored
and then you're left alone uh you're
left accleron yeah extracts one from
dee's head
and you still have one in your head
and
twitter is still question mark so i
forgot about that sorry
it's each each play session is formatted
the same way where i just i type the
word introduction that's the name of the
first paragraph yeah and i just say
what's going on
like what's happening like what's the
deal like what's the vibe like what's
the state of affairs
so you know you look at
episode one i write
cecilton the name you the name of the
town you call home like i'm saying this
to you right like this is like [ __ ] i
gotta say before we start playing
so that way we have context so i
described the cecilton i described the
exterminators monster hunters and i
described there's like an emergency call
that you're going to go yeah and then
after that right away
i go um
uh there's a little more context but the
first thing after that is just
characters like who the [ __ ] right are
these players in this world so you speak
and so i go characters
and it's their name or it's just with a
light descript like one sentence it's
ultra minimal like bullet points
chancellor of sport paranoid selfish
offers potentially could offer them a
mistake in their team
man we missed that one gorgeous great
and then i description cannot speak and
only can communicated to
psychically or by drinking the tea i
would have loved to just get a share in
the ceases and crushers yeah
and then i have some family members or
friends from the town question mark
we'll see if how that works with this
was like before i get everyone's
backstory oh you know this ended up
being uh
the cleric yeah so i took that from d's
backstory i'm like yeah let's just have
a backstory character episode one right
yeah yeah in the first session uh
vinsilius
uh vincelis had a like a child or a
daughter
like an older daughter that didn't make
it into the piece because
um
like i write this and then i sit down
and like all right and i just cut some
stuff if i have too much [ __ ] i've
got
reverend mcallister i got bongo's ex-12
which was what i named the automaton
and then we got the bridge zombie miners
um you know
you're going to there's the mining
thread okay yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
full circle
that whole thing like that
just to tip you off like
the undead miners at the very first
episode yeah is a thing right
yeah so um
and then then after that i just uh have
a little brief note that maybe
summarizes some character other
additional character relationship stuff
um
you know i'm like all right how does
what are like things that everyone may
or may not react to such as hey if the
party just kills the person with the
infected person
uh it could cause total chaos it's going
to cause complete chaos
if anyone finds out because there's a
murder in a party right um
and then i just
so then anyway so it's characters so
it's introduction yeah we go to
characters which is honestly i think the
most important part it's because that's
like the true web of the whole story as
long as the characters are kind of
figured out you're like okay like plot
will happen if you just put all these
people in a room yeah it's that it's
kind of like writing a little bit too of
just
figuring that out but then the next part
is super
important it's layout and that's
basically going all right
what where what what locations are there
on the map what or even just rooms what
are the rooms called and what is like
the one
or two special things about that
location is there gonna be a secret door
yeah is this just where all the money is
is this like a trap here you know just
like
treasure room yeah keeping it like
really really tight that's a great
philosophy for writing by the way let me
just point that out you said it really
quickly
the idea of not thinking about the plot
but thinking about the characters and
putting all the characters in the same
room and then just having the plot
happen because all those characters are
in a room i'm going to use that yeah
it's like what happens if these two
characters go to the sinkhole what
happens if these two characters go to
the dining hall like what types of
scenes you know like
just between the like this concept of
layout and the concept of these
characters you start to get scenes that
happen what if these two characters run
into each other in the bathroom you know
and then the last one
uh sorry
there's two more so we go intro
context characters important layout
important because it's a game board then
there's two final ones which is events
meaning
um
like it's like it's fuses so we're
lighting fuses here so it's like what
what [ __ ] goes down that could
potentially surprise people and push
things forward if things slow down or
need direction and
they can they're they're flexible where
it's like
what are the events in the first episode
um if they don't deal with greg right
away we'll have a mind flare fight
episode one you know yeah um and you
deal with it swiftly um
other events
all the infected people you met
earlier later were there at the party so
events
that means like okay these characters
are going to try and eventually leave
before you're ready
to stop them right uh so that could
potentially you know that that's that
could have been a whole other plot which
is like one person's infected what if
you guys were like
okay we know one is who else
you know and you've went that route well
it's like cool i've got a whole story
here i've got all the characters listed
that's the whole event contact tracing
yeah
um the mercenaries
who come
that was a thing too
um that eventually will jump out at
someone
um and all that stuff and then last so
that's
second to last the true last one for any
play session is directions which is
going
like
where like where like just trying
like yeah things could go in any
direction but
like let's lay out some paths here like
ahead of time
just so that way when when spontaneous
actions happen you can at least just
slightly direct them in a way that
logically can build towards a conclusion
yeah um so for the first play session
the first two episodes what are the
directions
um
some people want the player mindfully to
survive
and become a slave
maybe that's that's a maybe that is the
ending of that second episode it's alive
someone has taken it um maybe the mind
flare if it becomes a mind flare the
mind player itself decides to try and
escape and we're now in the caverns or
something like that
um
other directions they deal with it and
now have to find the other people in
town right
save the children question mark because
there was a whole subplot that never was
explored of
hijinks children that was happening in
the first two episodes which
just never got there
um and then big big overall directions
which is
find the high cleric in wentingham shire
right who's the one character like from
that first play session it's like that's
the one character that can actually just
kind of snap his fingers and help the
situation right right
so yeah that's basically like the layout
there where it's like okay intro context
characters motivations etc physical
layout
what are where the room's going to be
what are we doing and then we have
uh
the
the yeah sorry sorry
yeah event events which is you know
spontaneous things to have happen yeah
and then directions which is
all right where are we where are we
going with this what do we before we
even start playing that first episode
what do we want like the third or fourth
episode to feel like
and where where are we going with this
so
that's and then yeah each each play
session has a similar
format as far as like all right these
are the things you got to figure out
yeah
so a couple things
uh for next campaign
um i don't think we got to be very
careful about
like
when we went in vinsilius's house we
were just like murder everything
which is great it's a good way to get
this i feel like we're gonna get into
some trouble if we keep doing that well
that that's kind of why i like doing it
so you go back to the call of wild
campaign that was literally what we all
decided no i know let's actually try
murdering everything i really wanted
that was the coolest campaign ever an
emotionally driven murder revenge story
it's like a cowboy western it's just
it's just like so pure and like innocent
and perfect yeah you're just like you
never you never get to see that story in
movies or anything it's like what if we
did just not stop until our shores were
cleansed of this foreign threat
and it kicks it off with like a whole
like oh that one act totally justifies
this
okay like there's motivation now for
everything wow
yeah it's like oh yeah we burned your
village down and gave you poison
blankets and you're like okay let's kill
everyone
and so the whole time it's like every
once in a while there's morally
questionable moments where like is this
too much killing
you know and then everyone was like even
if it was a little too much everyone's
like yeah that was a little too much but
whatever you know we're committed
it's like it's okay like you think like
actual murderous dictators ever ask
themselves that do you think they're
ever like
is this too much killing
yeah but none of them have like a really
good backstory that like
justifies it
you know hitler wasn't like my family
was killed by the jews yeah installing
they took everything from me and my
village and left it in flames it's like
no no that's not that was that dark
medieval beginning no yeah
man
yeah i'm really excited for uh for
what's gonna happen next because i don't
know it's just such a fun game it's
pretty dope yeah yeah we all killed it
so sam are you ever going to have us do
the drunk history
voice
i don't think so something i don't want
to do that it doesn't seem necessary
like i want to find more creative ways
to film the shots
yeah and so we can get more more actual
information out of them yeah and like i
think that's the big my big goal anyways
is just like get a little bit more out
of it like i'd much rather it be like
rather than just showing you guys in an
area it would be like showing you guys
and the area
and making it really feel like that
it would be really great to get some 3d
monsters and characters in there
into some of those shots yeah rigging
that stuff can be kind of tough oh yeah
it's a ton of it's a it's a huge body of
work that needs to be accomplished it
would have to be like
maybe like one per episode
i feel like the greatest strength of
those green screen shots is showing us
in the space like basically the space
like okay the door is there the window's
there they're in a room like just
feeling the space is such like an
important aspect of this i mean you have
this whole board built out but yeah
totally yeah it's totally it's possible
just with the stuff we're filming on it
was it was pretty
limiting
right i mean it was still great but yeah
like yeah it was
well i mean also
we were you know we a bigger green
screen would make that a lot easier
where it's like okay we can actually
have a shot where everyone walks
together it's a group 10 feet into room
on a wide-angle lens
and we then look around should we do
like a two-sided or three-sided one next
time where we got a corner that would do
because like we originally said before
we shot the actual green screen we were
going to do an l
shape the corner the corner would fix
that okay yeah quite easily yeah let's
definitely do that next time
um and then you would be would be great
is if we can get another uh artist on
the compositions so that
either yourself or a 3d artist could
really focus on um
the monsters and the other characters
that we can't actually film live action
yeah
after doing the uh what is it
after doing that last shot with like the
drivers character and all the people
like yeah and also all this mocap stuff
it's like i'm starting to get the hang
of animation yeah jordan's pretty good
at rigging stuff too and yeah it's like
it's it doesn't take that long to rig
stuff but it's one of those
it's it's it's an endless
tunnel of work if you you know it's like
all right what are we gonna animate what
aren't we gonna animate
and it has to be it's something it's a
decision that absolutely has to be made
after everything's edited like you have
like all right here's like close to
final edits of everything you're like
all right what's like what does this
story need now no you don't want to like
do too much that ahead of time unless
it's like pretty obvious characters but
yeah
what would be an awesome
like season four or five or six goal
would be to
actually generate the maps and in um
see in 3d space beyond just the photo
scans
but actually build them
you know
and like make them like put ceilings on
them and stuff yeah ceilings and you
know yeah and then and then
if you had a true 3d environment that
you know you could where you could
actually adjust like objects
and lighting uh and and um
you know we're off to a great start we
have a huge asset library now yeah uh
but
yeah
yeah i mean the big thing is like all
right if you're using the scans there's
a quality
like
limit right effectively that's what i'm
saying um and
i don't know there's probably a way to
figure that out better in the future
like a lot of it looks pretty decent but
there's still a little here and there
wait dwarven forge said they would give
us 3d
models of everything they don't have 3d
models they have um what is it they have
like the resin masters
speak okay yeah but they're like not
painted or anything too like
the best way to do it
and the painful way to do it is to not
scan the game board but instead
scan the individual pieces
and then rebuild the whole map
but i don't but that's what i'm saying i
really don't want to do that because
that's
so much work right but that's like a
good like season six you know
goal but that's the way you would make
everything looking like real real real
good then you could do photo real
environments it would look very
realistic yeah but
you know i think we can
we're getting pretty close some of it
looks pretty good yeah but we changed
the photo scanning technique twice
as we're scanning stuff yeah
um which is why that last map i think
looks kind of the best right now like
blast stuff looks yeah
pretty dece but yeah
yeah getting there
it's really cool being able to just like
build this thing and photo scan it and
have
this incredibly
highly detailed asset just in 3d yeah it
is it's mind-blowing um
i i think it's it's it's crazy like yeah
i
how do i say it um yeah
what made the show really exciting for
me
other than having a fun dnd game was
going all right unreal five photo
scanning like crazy it's like what's
like what's the what's the most creative
way to get
all this stuff
with putting the least amount of effort
right i mean still a ton of effort but
like it's maybe that's the wrong way to
put it how do i maximize the energy i
put into this right
like that's i think the best way to
like uh put it and so
i feel like that that kind of worked
what are you most proud of
well uh the story
yeah no uh
um
i mean i don't know it's just it's it's
super cool it's like eight hours and
like yeah it's d and yeah there's
dudes playing a tabletop game
but
as you watch it with the way we're
adding some music and all these other
shots it's like it feels way bigger than
a board game as you watch it yeah yeah
and that's that's really what i
am proud of is because
like that's the feeling you're you get
when you play the game and
just you know like imagine watching
someone play checkers or something
imagine watch it's like hey guys we're
all getting together to play risk and
someone's like can i watch and it's like
it's like dude this is
the worst night of your life
like you're so bored like 30 minutes in
you're just gonna be on your phone you
know and and like that's that was the
issue too with d it's like all right how
do you like tap into that and
i mean the live action green screen
stuff helps but even still just like
super cinematic shots of what's
happening on the game board and then
making sure there's like a score like
emotionally driving the piece and going
all right this is creepy this is epic
this is scary this is fun like and just
like making sure you're always like
pumping that
so carmichael's sound design makes it
feel bigger too oh yeah the sound design
and the unreal shots too it's like so
cool there's so many things that we'll
say and then there'll be a sound effect
for and in the back your head you don't
even
notice that it's there but all of a
sudden it's you know it's just more
visceral yeah
the big thing like the the difference
between playing d d and versus filming
it though it's like that's been a
question we've been talking about as far
as like all right
uh uh how do you make it feel as fun as
d d but still like cut out some of the
baggage of dnd to make it so it's
a better story to listen to yeah you
know like all right do we take out
certain dice rolls for things to make
things go faster it's like as you
experienced you can have like three
conversations on three different parts
of this town
in the time it takes for you to like
fight two orcs yeah you know yeah
that's another thing
we should play next and how do you how
do you make that fair so that you don't
die fast too right you know because
that's you don't want if like combat's
so deadly where it's like haha dead dead
it's like combat for you would be you
walk into a room you're ambushed
everyone dies
it's like [ __ ] like like i don't you
don't want that experience either so
it's like what's that balance of of
making the fighting in combat
uh like is
making making it closer on the game
table as it is to how we've edited it
you know that's the that's the
like i want to bridge that gap a little
bit more so that way you have to hone in
on the storytelling aspect of combat
storytelling but i was like
a little less getting a little less
technical with like the the minutia we
try to i think next next
campaign we
when it comes to the decision making we
all basically it's like everyone says
what they want to do
and then
you know everybody basically takes one
turn and you go okay this is what i want
to do this okay okay now let's do this
you know and then it's just
then you're not sitting there
i know that's a little bit of natural
like debate having the time to discuss
is what leads to cool stuff happening on
the board like if we don't ever like
it does pause the fighting and it does
slow it down but at the same time
it's like you can't just show up to a
like if you went to a movie set you had
to do a fight scene you can't just make
it up on the spot and have it be real
you know true i think honestly i was
just
like i have tried using egg timers in
the past
yeah to just like
be like all right you know come to a
conclusion you know and and people
knowing that if they interject when
someone else is making a decision it
means you were eaten into that time
right and that like i wouldn't use that
often but like all right let's say it is
like a big mega boss battle it's like
all right so let's say they can do these
extra actions and stuff it's like okay
you're fighting you're doing i've got a
timer and whether it's his turn or not
when the timer runs out something's
going to happen yeah and just like just
just keep maybe move that yeah that's
cool like there's
there's some ways to push it but yeah
you're ultimately right though nico
because like
once again a d d conversation everyone
gets to talk about
what to do and yeah like the fights
aren't technically any different it's
just that
there's you know we're slowing time down
to
you know we you do fancier matrix moves
dodging our bullets when the time goes
slow yeah exactly it's like constant
it's in slow motion basically
all the dialogue and role-playing stuff
is real-time combat slow motion
and the other thing is when we're
speaking
as the characters we don't say like
you speak as that character right you
know playing as that character more than
then just uh that would make editing a
lot easier too yeah
just
super small stuff but then in the edit
there's no ambiguity about what's who's
saying what
you know
the the i think the thing that makes
like dungeons and dragons content
particularly interesting is you get
you get the like storytelling and the
world building of
fictional things like movies
but you get the
emotional hook of sports which are real
life games you know you don't know the
outcome anything could happen you have a
team's favorite to win totally so it's
like imagine watching game of thrones
but there's an actual dice roll and at
some point a character if they roll a
one dies and then the story just has to
completely adapt and change when that
happens and i feel like that aspect of
reality is what like draws me in and
lets me forget about the jank and the
lack of actual actors and like you know
it's
i get pulled into the story because
because there's that reality edge to it
it's the same thing like that hooks you
into vlogs like if somebody shot a movie
with the plot line of like
our vlogs the movie would probably not
be that compelling that would be really
artsy independent film that gets a lot
of awards in sundance
that no one watches everyone
[Laughter]
but when it's reality you have a totally
different context and a different hook
and it just like it pulls you in more
and that's what happens to me with the
dungeons and dragons games yeah i saw
people like commenting too it's like is
this scripted this feels kind of
scripted yeah it's like no it's edited
but you know like that might be what
makes it feel so scripted is because
it's it's streamlined and it's like
digestible yeah but yeah that's that's a
that's a cool take on it
especially from a viewer's perspective
yeah of like okay
everyone is genuinely ready to
react to anything and like you you don't
know what's gonna happen what i'm
excited about is just that there's no
limit on how
much we can do with it
um
in the uh
who's out there just people the dudes
just the dudes just the boys
there's no limit on how
far we can take it
like if you're setting out to do a
scripted piece or you know something
that's set in like a very particular way
you can
sure it might take a lot to get there or
it might take a little to get there
but once you're there it's done
you know and it's like okay you want to
do a situational comedy you want to do
uh you know a drama whatever like okay
here you are okay you've got the
characters they're portraying the
they're portraying the characters the
talent's portraying the characters
perfect more actual information out of
them yeah and like i think that's the
big my big goal anyways is just like get
a little bit more out of it like i'd
much rather it be like rather than just
showing you guys in an area it'd be like
showing you guys
and the area
and making it really feel like that it
would be really great to get some 3d
monsters and characters in there
into some of those shots
yeah rigging that stuff can be kind of
tough
like
maybe like one per episode
i feel like the greatest strength of
those green screen shots is showing us
in the space like basically the space
like okay the door is there the window's
there they're in a room like just
feeling the space is such like an
important aspect of this i mean you have
this whole board built out yeah totally
yeah it's totally it's possible just
with the stuff we're filming on it was
it was pretty
limiting right i mean it was still great
but yeah like yeah it was
well i mean all the mic
sam what are the things you like best
about each character
that the players played
all right that made you excited about
having each character okay well
obviously starting with your character
you you you always put a lot of focus on
making very powerful characters and like
yeah and like making sure that
everything
that works together to be better and so
it's kind of nice because
your character kind of becomes the whole
like hey i can step in and like really
[ __ ] [ __ ] up for everyone like in a very
good way it's like i can i can i can
make any situation grind to a complete
halt if i wanted to i like being able to
be a pain in somebody i gotta take a
little bit more of that for my character
next time but jake's character on the
other hand is like the social version of
that yeah you played like you played the
socialite bard character really well
good and like i it's it what created a
ton of the funniest moments too in the
in the show which is
i mean
it's it's great having that that element
when you're like
when you're playing the cleric can you
go who should i heal
which one is better
and then punches me after yeah
yeah but like you like you were also you
know very eager to take the lead too in
a lot of situations to kind of like all
right let's figure it out there's the
character you know no but like you that
was literally your character which is
like all right i'm supposed to be the
organizer of the group yeah and so it it
plays really well um i think dee's
character uh
i
i really appreciated how much backstory
d gave me yeah and it wasn't like a high
like volume but it was just very
specific yeah it was like here's here's
it was only like two paragraphs in an
email but it was like here's the names
here's the locations
and
like here's a little more extra context
context but it was like oh this is like
this is a this is still a ton
because now i can go all right like
well the game's taking place in the
world that context
exists in as well so
it's a perfect way to make the story get
way more personal and not be just like
hey there's a big dragon who wants to
fight it it's like oh was there an
orphanage before dee like said he was an
orphan or um
nope did you add that okay no i was like
like cause i told him i'm like you're
from this town yeah tell me something
about your character and what you did in
it okay and like i'm i'm just like i'm
we're working on building this out and
so he's like my character's from an
orphanage nearby the town like
there's an orphanage here right now
yeah yeah but like that's really
important you know that's like that's
where it becomes collaborative i feel
like it was dee's character that made
for the most movie-like moments
throughout this like the actual like
plot moments like episode six when
twimothy gets stolen or even just
episode one where he finds like father
mcallister like in this
kind of debate she has the sad shots
like yeah
you get to dip into the sad shots too
yeah but he has like three sad totally
like and that that means that's a lot
that's like oh this is like a thing a
character cares about yeah yeah you know
and it's like it's it i know that so he
became kind of like the
really the the the emotional like but
it's good that's like you need that yeah
yeah it's really cool i'd like to i mean
i will just preface that i will be
asking for a little bit more from you
guys too okay for the next one like jake
i got like some good stuff
i'm not going to try and i don't want to
overdo it but yeah we'll see where it
goes don't don't
don't don't put too much thought into it
don't like put too much pressure right
now give me some more reference to
create like a season defining storyline
because it's once again as i said it's
not about volume you know it's like
little things right it's little things
that you can pick up on
and so on and so forth so and then uh
wren
uh
i i i
ren was good at being impulsive
i think he needs to be more impulsive
though because like when he is impulsive
about things and does get fed up and
just goes like i'm doing this i don't
give a [ __ ] about anyone like it's great
and it drives things and it like keeps
things moving and
we stopped him too many times yeah
there's a lot of stopping like first
episode is like the very first
confrontation you have is like there's a
door
and he's like i'm gonna knock on it i
was like don't knock on it and they
spent 10 minutes talking about why you
shouldn't knocking knock on it and then
you just knock on it
yeah
he gets to the point yeah we cut most of
that out but yeah even still like i
still that's that's also really great to
have too
so
interesting those are really cool
insights into like what makes the
characters work i really want to find
out more about what dee had to do to
become a witch hunter yeah
what did he have to
he said he died and came back to life
yeah i guess what is this i guess he had
to like touch the void so i need to i
want him i want to hear this story needs
to come out somehow i'm gonna yeah
needs to come out and and and be known
the one thing that i would have loved to
like we it happened but it kind of all
got cut but it was great for the table
but like our characters gambling
addictions yes we never got we never got
we tried we tried a lot but never quite
there was like always like something
that was like very clearly more
important happening
yeah we need to do we got a little bit
for the sports game that actually ended
up happening yeah but that's true we
gambled a large sum of gold a very large
film of gold and it did not
so i'm wondering i don't know if our
characters are the good guys by the way
no yeah no you're the good guys we're
definitely the good guys well no my
character thinks of himself as a good
guy but after that after that match on
the sports field i'm not sure
you you definitely did not show mercy
no no that my my favorite [ __ ] scene
is nico going like here's a gold coin
orc
like it was a good fight and you turn to
everyone and you're like look
you you you like you make more some
things with honey or whatever yeah catch
more flies you catch more flies with
money he's got a gold coin everyone's
like he's just gonna go back
and tell everyone what happened
and he's like i shoot him in the head
with the crossbows he's walking away
[Laughter]
and then immediately it's like reveal
like oh yeah he was totally gonna go
tell everyone about what's happening
yeah
so yeah but i don't even understand why
we
still i i'm struggling with like why did
we kill those guys
it was it was just you got caught up in
the moment in the rage like there's a
little bit of brawling happening right
and like it just kind of got carried
away i've actually like punched one of
them to death no no here's the thing
here's the thing you guys ended up just
knocking everyone out you were very
specific too it was like it's a sports
brawl right you knock you ko everyone
except the
and then and then basically what happens
is uh he thought he was gonna die and
then he runs over and gets his sword
yeah he one guy grabs a sword but you
you knock him out you knocked out you
you managed to not knock everyone
unconscious and then what happens is
that you guys proceed to like talk to
these ghosts who i think it was like a
thing where it's like oh like
uh hold on
oh no one guy dies and then you're like
well
like okay let's bury him and the ghosts
are like oh like
yeah like i
was it was confusing i can't remember
but it was more like uh okay one's dead
so we might as well just kill everyone
[Laughter]
yeah so that was like kind of yeah that
wasn't good
but it was funny because if we do that
too many times i i don't know
my character was chaotic neutral so yeah
i have a meter i have a meter of all
your good actions and bad actions
and they'll eventually come to help or
haunt you right
yeah but your character's supposed to be
a good yeah my character is good he
knows people like i thought you know
gold coin
i mean same thing with like this is a
plot point that i really appreciated
which was
the mindless thrall that uh we're coming
to break that mind flair out of the jail
yeah and we're in a position where it's
like okay here's like 20 people
and
we can't like we're not supposed to but
like we can't just murder all of them
because they're innocent they're just
under mind control i didn't i didn't
take on that one i i shot two of them
with a with a ballista yeah i'm glad you
guys showed a little restraint because
if you did just like murdering all them
it kind of defeats the whole interest
in the process though so i suppose it
was fair dude tiny hut though tiny hat
is like clutched tiny hud is what really
like made that whole scene work is
because you were like all right here's
just like a force field no one can get
in it and it's just like we're blocking
the entrance yeah yeah and so we didn't
have to murder everybody then
yeah
that shirt's to be available by the way
yes yeah we it's not going to be
available by the time episode 8 is out
but it's going to be available in about
two weeks
yeah it's pretty pretty great do we have
any like we're only we're only printing
150 of them oh man at least 10 of those
are going into quarter people
do you have any like sick black friday
merch dropping or oh a ton oh yeah yeah
the bomber jacket 2.0 right it's been
two years in development
uh it's guaranteed tested in every
weather condition it has they sent me
like
we made two modifications out of the uh
manufacturing facility where they sent
me blanks of the jacket
and
terms of fitment and like feel and like
everything
and then we finally got that and then
and then we put this sweet map that gabe
made on the inside of it that has all
these different locations where we
filmed um in los angeles that's really
cool yeah it's going to be awesome
um and then there's a bunch of other
good stuff too but if you wouldn't
believe it if i told you but nobody is
printing
green
key green fabric
yeah and so i asked jay today i was like
well can if no one's printing it can we
just make it like how how many yards do
we have to print to like you know this
here's a green there's gotta be
somebody needs green fabric yeah you
know we do it's used and stuff yeah yeah
like how do you make like renaissance
fair costumes right you need green maybe
not key green for red and fair maybe
yeah who knows
anyways
and then i'm trying to get a pillow made
this isn't out yet but i'm trying to get
a pillow made where it's uh green
emergency green screen on the outside
and then you flip the cover and it's a
reflector
that's such an inside joke
the funniest thing about the green
screen blanket though is that people
actually buy it for as a green screen
yeah because that's it is truly an
emergency green screen
we're sold out of them i can't get any
more maid
that's the best right and it also is a
blanket
i can't believe we're even getting any
merch right now with the whole supply
chain can we make emergency morph suits
yes like an emergency onesie morph suit
but they already make green morph suits
yeah they do i just make green yeah but
what if it's like wearable like artists
i mean like already like sweats
yeah like we do socks sweats and a shirt
well i'm just saying man
like a track suit no just make it one
article like a onesie like
an adult onesie okay yeah because then
it's like it's it's like comfortable
green fabric it's not tight it's not
spandex yeah green green uh fabric is
our greatest enemy right now
if we had a supplier of green fabric we
could make this i'm just saying that's
the next level one which is there's got
to be somebody who's making it fabric
it's like
a puppet this like practical monster
head and we're gonna have to key you out
but i want you to be comfortable when
you do it yeah let's be real you're not
gonna keep me you're gonna rode with me
so yeah let's be honest yeah yeah so i
can wear whatever i want right yeah so
i'll wear this quarter digital green
screen onesie
then it's just a super hard roto because
you can't see the edge
yep
yeah i don't believe that there's if
you're listening and you know somebody
who's manufacturing uh
basic cotton
can you dye it green and give us a call
i how is this disgusting chroma green
though right well yeah which is actually
kind of bs just
bright green will work yeah yeah any
bright green would do
any yeah
so that's not asking for more they keep
i keep i fast like three times i was
like really they're sold out no one's no
one's making green fabric
actually if you if you get it slightly
reflective so you put like a ring light
around the camera just it just bumps it
a little bit
maybe we can add in like a thread yeah
into the stitch that makes it slightly
reflective that 511 jacket that i have
like from battlefield days
like that has a slightly reflective
quality to the there we go
see the thing is you gotta you gotta
play at this game though it's like how
much do you want your green screen
track suit to cost
you know i've spared no expense spare
luxury luxury luxury it's gonna
see how much people are willing to pay
for crappy t-shirts
professional grade not our t-shirts our
t-shirts aren't crappy no our teachers
are wonderful but like yeah people are
out there like here's a white t-shirt
500 seems like oh right because it's
five hundred dollars i want it like
gucci yeah yeah oh my god that's
disgusting
it's the perfect chroma green i mean it
would have to be the perfect chroma
green though that's the thing
yeah it would have to be the perfect
chroma green it would have to be nice
and it
would probably cost over a hundred
dollars to provide that
probably probably well over
casa lots to look this good you know
yeah
that'd be so cool though
hey guys
this is a little this guy's so it's just
me sam and jake on the couch here and
this little hint of what our meetings
actually go like
yeah i'm kind of turning this into a
meeting yeah this is kind of how they
actually sound
how can we make a green tracksuit that's
slightly reflective
that costs less than 200 dollars you
just hope somebody listens podcast is a
fabric manufacturer seriously i gotta
call my buddy i went to law school with
this guy who's dad i got a buddy can get
you a real good greeting i got buddies
for everything man
um no i got i got a guy
i went to law school with him his dad
has a uh
garment what do you call it textile
supply
out of the fashion district and uh he's
gotta know he's gotta know something
maybe he's got some green he's probably
got some green in there up in there yeah
we need and then you do like the little
silver
you know retro reflective
retro-reflective yeah silver
and uh
we need a loom
[Laughter]
one green string and then one shiny one
and then we can do the thing where you
push it up and down
because if we made a deal with aperture
where like it comes with two lights oh
yeah
it comes with two like m10 lights
interesting yeah
anyways
uh
cool keep an eye on quarterdigital.story
sometimes what's funny is i was
explaining this to uh matt and jordan
today
or maybe it's matt oh so i'm gonna have
jordan take pictures of everybody who's
wearing the same thing i think it's a
great idea because it happens every day
yeah and so griffin and jordan were
wearing the same thing today and then i
was explaining to them how
we don't make like any money on merch at
this point it's like yeah we make a
little bit but it's basically just like
uh to feed the habit of like
how can we get a green track series
yeah
and like
i'm not sure people listening to this
podcast like fully understand how
moe's like
probably 60 of everybody's wardrobe at
corridor at this point is just the
corridor merch like really the merch
is just so all of us have clothes it's
just a perk yeah
yeah it's like if you work with us we
will put clothes on you
section 4d additional compensation
clothing various shirts and pants
once a quarter once a quarter you will
yeah
you can formally request up to three
articles of clothing
which is not too far from the truth it's
like here's the thing here's a real
question when you make these power
jackets they'll probably make what like
a hundred or something like that yeah
we're probably gonna see there's like 15
people working at corridor yeah 15 of
those are going to disappear instantly i
think we're making
a little bit more than that i think
we're making like 500. oh good maybe wow
maybe not that that's plenty yes they
get so expensive yeah like imagine like
hey so we want to make 500 jackets and
then you get a bill for 34 000 and
you're like
maybe i didn't want that many yeah it's
like
yeah does anyone want some jackets
i guess
that's basically our merch business
right there
it's like hey guys i mean you new shirts
like what are we gonna do with the extra
400. it's like oh crap all right
i like it yeah i'll tweet maybe i'll put
a tweet out and see if anyone knows some
more maybe somebody else wants something
yeah that is kind of how much
the merch is just to wrap it yeah if you
like corridor
that's why we started doing it
originally yeah back way back six seven
years ago when we first started uh
selling shirts it was it was just
because people kept asking for it
and then um we were just people being
also a bunch of people in the office
yeah that too
and and then we just started printing
them carmichael and i for a long time
were just
we had a whole system and we'd get you
know maybe like five eight orders a day
and you just have to slap the label on
it and then
check it off the inventory spreadsheet
and then i'd go to this guy down the
street and i'd go okay hey man i need 12
shirts
[Laughter]
you need two it was like these abysmally
low inventory numbers
uh
yeah
good times
and i get so many like spam emails too
from companies being like hey i wanted
to introduce you to our merchandising
branch we could help you merchandise
things with things like custom shirts
hats water bottles like have you even
taken like 30 seconds like just type our
name into google yeah
yeah
yeah probably not
no i know i and a lot of it's like janky
like print to order yeah that stuff
sucks i know i i'm like so burned like i
got a really dope shirt from a band i
like yeah and uh
i watched it once and it fell apart
right like this sucks like and i like i
i'm talking to the guy on instagram from
the band like i haven't told that to him
yet
but like he was like hey love your music
is like hey i've seen those react videos
like cool and then my follow-up is uh so
uh
where do you have the good ones the good
shirts
who is selling the good ones because i'd
like to buy one of the good shirts
please
funny story i got one of the bad ones
i'm not asking you for a refund but
it's like
guitar in this man
yeah
i didn't even know we were selling merch
like
hey i recognize your reacts yeah i was
just out of the blue i've started to
realize that like hey most people on
instagram will respond if you send them
a message and so i just was like hey
congrats on your cool album that's what
happens when you have 14 million
subscribers on youtube you got a blue
check
i do i submitted it facebook has
all my information now i'm in the maid
of verse oh damn i know they've made a
digital copy of me yeah and all the
shirts i've bought
[Laughter]
good one bad one yeah
yep
yeah how about i don't even know if i
want to talk about it no i'm not talking
i just want a riff on it
there's been many verses before i don't
why are they making it's just it's just
a parent company isn't it it's like
alphabet and google and i think they're
also realizing that trying to call
everything the facebook thing is just a
weird name oculus by facebook but
facebook's a really crappy company and
you know
i don't know i know it's like how much
like they have to they have to start
paying people
to participate in this may diverse thing
you know
that's the only way people are is there
a social element to this it's like kind
of the oculus system right now
okay but but it's like how annoying like
dude
this is weeks of weeks old now but you
saw the dc like their launch video yeah
it came out it's like how imagine you're
playing a vr game with your friends and
a freaking like video call interrupts it
yeah and you're like forced on screen to
have this like alert that someone's
trying to video chat with you in the
middle of playing a video game screw
that it's like what it's like this
that sucks it's like if i'm yeah like i
don't want that kind of crap yeah i
don't want that kind of made averse
where i'm like i'm trying to have fun
and then like someone's like
do you think
i'm playing a freaking game do you think
like these tech billionaires get so into
like their own like universe where
they're like hey this is this is a good
idea we should do this and and to the
average person
the answer is no i don't want that yeah
my life definitely i think that's
absolutely right it's really just about
prodding you it's like here's the thing
you like and we're just gonna figure out
how much we can just jab you in the side
and make it uncomfortable before you go
screw it you just take the headset off
and never play it again yeah we do it
just can we bug you five percent of the
time right i hate that yeah
it's the worst trying to figure you out
to
actually make so much money and like
i just wish
everybody would figure that out and stop
letting them get away with that [ __ ]
yeah cause the reason they do is people
pay the frickin money for it it's like
if we all just would have [ __ ] gut it
up and not done that then we wouldn't be
here with crappy dlc and
microtransactions yes and instagram with
ads
instagram now with ads
oh great it's like
there's no amount of money you can pay
them yeah because that's a way yeah well
that's that's how they do it they you
know you do the free product version i
mean youtube did the same thing
remember when the ads became a thing on
youtube and then and then
integrations and it was like
you know
still to this day there's comments
remember that guy
uh
on our discord we have this comment hall
of fame
where we post stuff sometimes
there was a guy who was like fame screw
you for having ads in your videos let's
see let's let's wrap up this uh let's
start with this podcast with some
comment hall of fame yeah honestly i'm
this is this is bad because now we're
gonna encourage people to get on the
comment hall of fame so don't take it
away like no
you get on the comment hall of fame
i'm trying to soften it there's there
hasn't been a good one yet like
a lot of people who just just throwing
this out there before anyone thinks
about making a troll post if you get on
the comment hall of fame you get blocked
on the channel generally too like that
means yeah
that was that your comment hall of fame
comment is your last comment
that anyone on any social networks
controlled by us is going to read
so
just saying just saying it's funny but
this is there's some funny ones are you
gonna read the one by uh we won't say
their names yeah don't say the names
also i will say i've been around the
internet i can tell people are faking it
and when they're sincere all right
if these greedy efforts stop until you
subscribe i will unsubscribe i might go
further prick them i'm self-censoring
frick them for having commercial breaks
to have ads about themselves imagine if
any other company did that
that's the imagination of any other
comment any other company did that had
commercial breaks to promote themselves
you mean like
everything every company
so i really like that one oh that's such
a good one that one had me dying
you are not god to criticize indian
cinema yeah
oh my god i cannot wait till the next
bollywood though because there's a movie
you know you know the cop who rides on
the hood of the jeep
that one that clip oh yeah uh the latest
movie in that saga came out like in the
last few weeks yeah here we go it's so
dope uh
this is why i don't watch willy wonka or
my baby sister and if she does i will
get mad because this is not a kids show
and it's about killing and this should
be stopped
pound it f you
it says willy wonka rated r with a gory
thumbnail
ah man this is a good one this video
could legit be called we examined and
critiqued andrew garfield's unaltered
face
it's just funny how the context of that
became such that that could have been
the actual title
i'm thinking about the healer machine i
wish it exists in real life that a lot
of soldiers life could be saved
yes we all wish that exists in real life
sorry half of the comment hall of fames
aren't
uh really aggressive no no no no they're
actually just like really sweet funny
yeah some of them yeah there's some
there's some there's something i'm not
reading
yeah non-repeatable ones that we
obviously block
yeah but they still make it to the hall
of fame yeah
good boy
all right well
good times thanks for answering all the
questions about son of a dungeon yeah
that's a great idea
i feel like you've uh interviewed guests
before for uh yeah man i just asked the
questions i want to know the answers to
right it's that easy
i'm just glad you guys enjoyed it and
had fun and are thinking the show's cool
that's like that's
just being able to continue playing d
quote unquote professionally is is
awesome so yeah a note on that everybody
who came into the site for the show has
literally made season two possible yeah
no not no exaggeration or
everyone that's come under the site has
changed
our entire business operation here at
corridor yeah and how completely yeah
yeah all of you have completely
redefined how we get to approach media
and making videos and films and super
super exciting like
it sounds super like
a crappy ceo on big stage in front of
people hyping everybody up changing
you are changing the way we make
entertainment yeah it hurts me to say it
but it's true no it's true well it's
it's it's a lot more authentic and like
oh god
authenticity
another buzz word
how to be authentic online
oh
but seriously like all the way up to
this point
at what point could you just be could
you just have somebody subscribe to your
work and then you give them the product
that's it no middlemen no distributors
no one else
pick and choose no advertisers to worry
about it's just we don't have an
algorithm here well maybe we have a
green light for that which is like
no screen
you know what no we green light an
anti-algorithm we specialize in 100
non-synthesized algorithm-free content
there you go digital.com
except for our recommended for you
taylormade that's it yeah it's like
going to a wood shop yeah all right
anyways signing off uh that was a great
cast sam thanks for putting all that
together i cannot wait
for season two
we're gonna try to film it in january
and i'm sticking to that
i don't know how it's gonna happen we're
gonna make it happen yeah it'll be a
piece of cake
everyone's experts at dmd now they know
the rules
yeah sort of
sort of
[Music]
do
you